เราคิดว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจะทำให้เราสามารถแก้ปัญหาบางอย่างได้เร็วกว่าที่เราทำได้ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกเพียงอย่างเดียว แต่
การเข้าใจว่ายังไงนั้นละเอียดอ่อน วันนี้ใน Qiskit in the Classroom เราจะพยายามค้นหาที่มาของพลังของ
การคำนวณควอนตัมโดยการมองหนึ่งในการ
algorithm แรกสุด ยินดีต้อนรับสู่ Qiskit in the Classroom ในซีรีส์นี้ เราจะใช้ Qiskit สำรวจแนวคิดพื้นฐานบางอย่าง
ที่มักครอบคลุมในคอร์สที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ quantum computing แต่ละวิดีโอมี interactive module
ลิงก์ในคำอธิบายด้านล่าง อย่าลืมเช็กดูนะ ถ้าคุณได้ยินเรื่อง quantum computer มาเยอะ คุณคง
ได้ยินมาแล้วว่ามันสามารถใช้ quantum phenomena อย่าง superposition, entanglement และ interference เพื่อแก้
ปัญหาในแบบที่คอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกทำไม่ได้ แต่คุณสมบัติเหล่านี้ช่วยยังไงกันแน่ ในปี 1985 David Deutsch เป็น
คนแรกที่แสดงให้เห็นว่ามันเป็นไปได้ยังไง เขาคิดค้นสิ่งที่ตอนนี้เรียกว่า Deutsche's algorithm ที่สามารถแก้
ปัญหาได้มีประสิทธิภาพกว่า classical algorithm วันนี้เราจะมองดู Deutsche's algorithm และ
extension ที่พัฒนาขึ้นมาทีหลังที่เรียกว่า Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm และตรวจสอบว่า quantum aspect เฉพาะตัวของ qubit
สามารถนำมาใช้ประโยชน์ให้กับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมได้ยังไง แล้วเราจะรัน algorithm เหล่านั้นบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจริงด้วย Qiskit
มี quantum algorithm อื่นๆ ที่ยังแสดงข้อได้เปรียบทางทฤษฎีเหนือ classical algorithm ที่รู้จักด้วย และไม่ใช่ทั้งหมดที่ทำงาน
ด้วยหลักการเดียวกับที่เราจะเห็นวันนี้ ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราจะเรียนรู้วันนี้ไม่ได้อธิบายโดยทั่วไปว่า quantum
computer ทำงานยังไง แต่มันช่วยให้เราเริ่มเห็นว่าหลักการของกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมสามารถรวมกันเพื่อ
สร้าง quantum computer ที่ทรงพลังได้ยังไง ก่อนที่จะลงลึกใน Deutsche's algorithm มาคิดก่อนว่า quantum computer
แตกต่างจาก classical computer ยังไง และสิ่งนั้นอาจให้ข้อได้เปรียบในการแก้
ปัญหาบางอย่างยังไง ความแตกต่างหนึ่งคือ quantum bit ที่เรียกว่า qubit สามารถอยู่ใน superposition state ได้ แทนที่จะ
จำกัดอยู่ที่ zero state หรือ one state อย่างที่ classical bit ทำ qubit
สามารถอยู่ใน superposition state ของทั้ง zero และ one เราเขียน state นี้
แบบนี้ โดยที่ a และ b เป็น complex number ที่กำลังสองของพวกมันรวมกันได้หนึ่ง และยิ่ง
qubit มากเท่าไหร่ ช่องว่างนี้ก็ขยายออกมากขึ้น สองบิตยังอยู่ได้ในเพียงหนึ่งใน
สี่ state ที่เป็นไปได้ 0 0, 1, 1 0 หรือ 1
1 สอง qubit สามารถอยู่ใน superposition ของ state ที่อนุญาตแบบคลาสสิกทั้งสี่นั้นได้ ซึ่ง
เขียนแบบนี้ โดยทั่วไป ระบบคลาสสิกของ n bit สามารถอยู่ใน combination ของ 0 และ 1 ที่เป็นไปได้เพียงหนึ่งจาก 2 ยกกำลัง n เท่านั้น
ระบบควอนตัมของ n qubit สามารถอยู่ใน superposition ของ 2 ยกกำลัง n state เหล่านั้นทั้งหมด
scaling เป็นแบบ exponential ดังนั้นแม้ว่าเรามีแค่ 10 qubit พวกมัน
สามารถอยู่ใน superposition state ของ 2 ยกกำลัง 10 ซึ่งคือ 1,024 combination ที่เป็นไปได้ของ 0 และ
1 การ scale แบบ exponential ของ state space ของ qubit เรียกว่า quantum
parallelism และมีส่วนรับผิดชอบบางส่วนต่อข้อได้เปรียบของ quantum computer เหนือ classical computer แต่ quantum
computer ไม่ใช่แค่ parallel processor ขนาดใหญ่ แค่เพราะ qubit ใน quantum computer สามารถอยู่ใน
superposition ของ state จำนวนมหาศาลแบบ exponential ไม่ได้หมายความว่าเราเข้าถึงข้อมูลทั้งหมดในแต่ละ
state เหล่านั้นได้ เนื่องจากการวัด collapse ระบบไปยัง state เดียว มาดูว่า
มันเป็นยังไงในปัญหาง่ายๆ สมมติว่ามีเครื่องจักรบางอย่างที่
คุณสามารถป้อน single bit ให้ จากนั้นมันจะใช้ฟังก์ชันบางอย่างกับ bit และคายออกมาเป็น single bit อื่น เครื่องจักร
อยู่ใน black box ที่เราเข้าถึงไม่ได้ สิ่งที่เราเข้าถึงได้คือแค่ bit
ที่เราป้อนมัน x และ bit ที่ box คายออกมา f
of x เราต้องการหาว่าฟังก์ชัน f ที่เครื่องจักรใช้คืออะไร
มีฟังก์ชันสี่อย่างที่เป็นไปได้ที่นำ single bit ไปยัง single bit อื่น
ดังนั้นเพื่อหาว่าฟังก์ชันเป็นอะไร เราสามารถป้อน 0 แล้วดูว่ามันคายออกมาเป็น 0 หรือ 1 จากนั้นป้อน
1 และทำเหมือนกัน แต่ละขั้นตอนเหล่านี้สองขั้นเรียกว่า query สิ่งนี้
เป็นวิธีหนึ่งในการเปรียบเทียบ classical และ quantum algorithm ผ่าน query model ที่เรียกว่า ที่เราเปรียบเทียบจำนวน
query ที่แต่ละ algorithm ต้องทำกับ black box เพื่อแก้ปัญหา ดังนั้นในกรณีนี้ วิธีคลาสสิกของเรา
ต้อง query box สองครั้งเพื่อเรียนรู้ฟังก์ชัน มาดูว่าเราทำได้ดีกว่านั้นไหมถ้า quantum
computer query black box แทนที่จะป้อน 0 ก่อนแล้วตาม 1
quantum computer สามารถป้อน qubit ที่อยู่ใน superposition ของ 0 และ
1 ให้กับ box ได้ ในทางปฏิบัติ เราป้อน input ทั้งสองให้ box ด้วย query เดียว แล้ว
นั่นหมายความว่าเราสามารถเรียนรู้ฟังก์ชันด้วย query เดียวเท่านั้นใช่ไหม
น่าเสียดาย ไม่ใช่อย่างนั้น เราเห็นว่าทำไมแนวคิดนี้จึงล้มเหลวเมื่อเราทดสอบมันบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม เราจะสร้าง
circuit ด้วยสอง qubit qubit 0 ที่แทนด้วยเส้นบนสุดนี้จะเป็น input state X ที่เราป้อนให้
black box ซึ่งแสดงที่นี่ด้วย gate สีน้ำตาลแดงที่มีป้าย UF UF gate ถูก
ออกแบบให้รับ qubit 0 เป็น input state X แล้วนำ transformation ไปใช้กับ qubit 1 ที่นำ
state 0 ไปยัง state f of x ดังนั้นตราบใดที่ qubit 1 เริ่มต้นใน state
0 output จะเป็น x บน qubit 0 และ f of x บน qubit 1 ดังนั้นเพื่อหา f of x สำหรับ
ทั้ง x=0 และ x=1 พร้อมกัน เราสามารถลองวาง qubit 0 ใน superposition ของ 0 และ 1 ก่อน
ที่เราป้อนให้ black box ทำโดยใช้ Hadamard gate สีแดงนี้ซึ่ง transform zero state เป็น 1 หาร 2 ราก
|0⟩ + |1⟩ ดังนั้นหลังจาก blackbox gate เราควรมี superposition ของทั้ง
f of 0 และ f of 1 บน qubit 1 เมื่อเราวัด qubit ทั้งสอง เราหวังจะ
ตอบคำถามว่า ฟังก์ชันอะไรอยู่ใน black box มาใช้ Qiskit primitive sampler รัน
circuit และ return ผลลัพธ์ เราสามารถเลือกจำนวนครั้งที่ circuit รัน ที่เรียกว่า sample โดยเปลี่ยน
parameter ที่เรียกว่า shots ตรงนี้
สิ่งนี้เทียบเท่ากับจำนวน query ที่เราทำกับ black box มาดูว่า query เดียวจะ
พอไหม นี่คือผลลัพธ์ เราวัด qubit 0 ได้เป็น 0 ดังนั้นนั่นคือ
input value x และ qubit 1 ได้เป็น 1 ซึ่งเป็น output value f of x ดังนั้นตอนนี้เรา
รู้ว่า f of 0 เท่ากับ 1 แต่แล้ว f of 1 ล่ะ นี่คือจุดที่มีปัญหา เมื่อ
เราวัด state แล้ว superposition collapse และเราวัดได้แค่ส่วนหนึ่งของฟังก์ชันด้วย
query เดียว สิ่งนี้ไม่บอกเราทุกอย่างที่เราต้องการรู้เพื่อกำหนดว่าฟังก์ชันเป็นอะไร เราต้องการ
query box ครั้งที่สองเพื่อสิ่งนั้น ดังนั้น แม้ว่าหลักการของ quantum parallelism ทำให้เราสามารถ
ให้ black box evaluate f of 0 และ f of 1 พร้อมกันได้ เราไม่มีสิทธิ์เข้าถึงคำตอบทั้งสอง
นั้น quantum parallelism เพียงอย่างเดียวยังไม่พอ Deutsche's algorithm
แสดงให้เห็นว่าเราสามารถใช้ quantum parallelism ต่างออกไปนิดเพื่อเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับฟังก์ชันใน black box ได้ เราจะ
ไม่สามารถเรียนรู้ว่าฟังก์ชันเป็นอะไรกันแน่ แต่เราจะสามารถเรียนรู้บางอย่างใหม่เกี่ยวกับมันด้วย
query เดียวที่เราทำไม่ได้ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก มาเริ่มด้วยการดูตารางของฟังก์ชันสี่อย่างที่เป็นไปได้ที่
นำ single bit ไปยัง single bit อีกตัว ที่นี่คุณเห็นได้ว่าสองฟังก์ชัน f_sub_1 และ f_sub_4 จะ
return ค่าเดียวเสมอโดยไม่สนใจ input state เราเรียกสองฟังก์ชันนี้
ว่า constant f_sub_2 และ f_sub_3 จะ return ทั้ง 0 หรือ 1 ขึ้นอยู่กับ
state ของ x เราเรียกสองฟังก์ชันนี้ว่า balanced Deutsche's algorithm
กำหนดว่าฟังก์ชันเป็น constant หรือ balanced โดยการปรับ circuit ที่เราใช้ก่อนหน้านี้อย่างฉลาด
นี่คือ circuit เริ่มต้นด้วยการเตรียม qubit 0 ให้อยู่ใน state 1 หาร
รากที่สอง 2 |0⟩ + |1⟩ ด้วย Hadamard เหมือนก่อน และ qubit 1 ใน state 1 หารรากที่สอง 2 |0⟩ - |1⟩
ด้วย NOT gate ตามด้วย Hadamard
ดังนั้น full state ณ จุดนี้นี่คือที่ state นี้คือ state ของ qubit 0 และ
นี่คือ state ของ qubit 1 การเตรียม qubit 1 ในแบบนั้นแทนที่จะ
ปล่อยมันใน state 0 ทำให้ algorithm สามารถใช้ quantum parallelism ร่วมกับ interference เพื่อเรียนรู้
เกี่ยวกับ blackbox function มาดูว่ายังไง เมื่อ qubit ถูกป้อนเข้า UF blackbox gate สองสิ่งสามารถ
เกิดขึ้น ถ้าฟังก์ชัน constant แล้ว black box จะทำ operation บน qubit 1 เพียงอย่างเดียวโดยไม่สนใจ
state ของ 0 ในกรณีนี้ เนื่องจาก UF ไม่แตะ qubit 0 หรือ
สนใจ state ของมันเลย Hadamard ตัวที่สองตรงนี้ก็แค่ undo สิ่งที่
Hadamard ตัวแรกทำ และเราจะวัด qubit ให้อยู่ใน state 0 มาดูฟังก์ชัน balanced f_sub_2 เป็นตัวอย่างเพื่อดูว่า
UF ทำอะไรกับ state ในกรณีนี้ เมื่อ x เป็น 0 f of x เป็น 0 และเมื่อ x
เป็น 1 f of x เป็น 1 จำที่ฉันบอกคุณเกี่ยวกับ UF gate ได้ไหม มันรับ qubit 0
เป็น input x state และ output f of x บน qubit 1 โดยสมมติว่า qubit 1
เริ่มต้นใน zero state ดังนั้นสำหรับฟังก์ชันนี้ สิ่งที่ UF ทำกับ qubit 1 ขึ้นอยู่กับ
qubit 0 ถ้า 0 เป็น 0 แล้ว qubit 1 จะถูกทิ้งให้อยู่ใน zero state เพื่อให้ได้ f
of x = 0 ถ้า qubit 0 เป็น 1 black box จะใช้ NOT gate กับ qubit 1 และวาง
มันใน state 1 ดังนั้นเราได้ f of 1 เท่ากับ 1 นี่คือสิ่งที่ controlled-NOT หรือ CNOT gate ทำอย่างพอดี
CNOT gate รับ qubit สอง ตัว qubit control และ qubit target และพลิก
state ของ qubit target ถ้า qubit control อยู่ใน state 1 แต่ไม่ทำอะไรกับ target ถ้า control
qubit อยู่ใน state 0 ดังนั้น UF สำหรับ F2 ก็แค่ CNOT บน Q0 และ Q1 CNOT
gate จะไม่ทำอะไรกับ term แรกเนื่องจาก control qubit อยู่ใน state 0 แต่ใน term ที่สอง
0 นี้พลิกเป็น 1 และ 1 นี้พลิกเป็น 0 และถ้าเรา factor minus sign ออกมา เราจะเห็นว่า state ของ qubit 1 คือ
ยังไม่เปลี่ยน แต่ term นี้ได้รับ minus sign ดังนั้น state ของ qubit 0 คือ
ตัวที่เปลี่ยนไปจริงๆ มันไปจากการเป็น 0 + 1 เป็น 0 ลบ
1 เมื่อเราใช้ Hadamard สุดท้ายกับ qubit 0 สิ่งนี้ transform มันเป็น state 1 ดังนั้นถ้าฟังก์ชันใน black box
เป็น f_sub_2 เราจะวัดได้ 1 แทนที่จะเป็น 0 ปรากฎว่า UF gate สำหรับ balanced function อีกตัว f3 คือ
CNOT gate เดียวกันตามด้วย NOT บน qubit 1 NOT gate สุดท้ายไม่ส่งผลกับ qubit 0 ดังนั้นเมื่อฟังก์ชัน
เป็น balanced เราจะวัด qubit 0 ให้อยู่ใน state 1 ตอนท้ายของ circuit ตอนนี้ถ้าคุณตาม
ไม่ทัน ก็ไม่เป็นไร แนะนำให้ลองทำด้วยตัวเองเพื่อดูว่ามันทำงานยังไง ประเด็นหลักที่นี่คือสิ่งที่
เกิดขึ้นเมื่อเราใช้ CNOT สำหรับ balanced function ทั้งสอง qubit 0 ถูกใช้เป็น control qubit เพื่อเปลี่ยน
state ของ qubit 1 โดยสัญชาตญาณ คุณอาจคิดว่า qubit 0 จะยังคงไม่เปลี่ยน และกระนั้น ด้วยวิธีบางอย่าง
operation ของเราบน qubit 1 จริงๆ แล้วเปลี่ยน state ของ qubit 0 โดยการเปลี่ยน relative phase ระหว่างสองส่วนของ
superposition ของมัน ปรากฏการณ์นี้เรียกว่ากลไก phase kickback และมัน
ขัดกับสัญชาตญาณมากเหมือนกับ quantum phenomena อื่นๆ มากมาย ในแง่หนึ่ง คุณสามารถคิดถึงกลไก phase kickback
เหมือนการพายเรือ การกระทำของการผลักน้ำไปข้างหลังจริงๆ ผลักคุณให้เดินหน้า เหมือนกับที่ operation บน
qubit 1 จริงๆ แล้วเปลี่ยน qubit 0 ตอนนี้เราสามารถรัน Deutsche's algorithm บน
Qiskit ได้ ที่นี่เราสามารถเลือกว่าฟังก์ชันไหนจะใส่ใน black box ซึ่งเราเลือกเป็น F3 นี่คือ
circuit diagram ของ algorithm และเราสามารถรันด้วย sampler primitive เหมือนก่อน เราจะตั้ง samples
แค่หนึ่งและดูว่าเราวัดได้อะไร ในกรณีนี้ เราวัดได้ 1
ดังนั้น เรารู้ว่าฟังก์ชัน balanced ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่เราคาดไว้เพราะ black box มีฟังก์ชัน f3 อยู่ ดังนั้นด้วย query เดียว
เราสามารถแยกแยะระหว่าง function class ทั้งสองนี้ได้
classical algorithm ต้องใช้ query สองครั้งเพื่อกำหนดสิ่งนี้ สิ่งนี้แสดงข้อได้เปรียบที่พอประมาณของ quantum
computing เหนือ classical computing เพียงอย่างเดียว แต่ไม่ได้น่าประทับใจมากนัก แค่หนึ่งต่อสอง แต่ Deutsche's algorithm
ยังคงสำคัญอย่างยิ่งต่อประวัติศาสตร์ของ quantum computing เพราะมันให้แรงบันดาลใจที่ทำให้คนอื่นๆ
เริ่มคิดถึง quantum algorithm ที่ใหญ่กว่าและซับซ้อนกว่า
ซึ่งรวมถึง multi-qubit extension ของ Deutsch's algorithm ที่แสดงข้อได้เปรียบควอนตัมที่น่าประทับใจกว่ามาก
นี่เรียกว่า Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm มันแก้ปัญหาที่คล้ายกัน แต่ในกรณีนี้ blackbox function
ที่เราต้องการเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับนั้นรับ n bits เป็น input และ output single bit ตามที่
ก่อนหน้านี้ เราได้รับสัญญาว่าฟังก์ชันจะเป็น constant ซึ่งหมายความว่า output bit เป็น 1 หรือ 0 เสมอ
โดยไม่สนใจ input bit string หรือ balanced ซึ่งหมายความว่า output เป็น 0 สำหรับ
ครึ่งหนึ่งของ input bit string และ 1 สำหรับอีกครึ่งหนึ่ง แน่นอนว่ามีฟังก์ชันอื่นๆ
ที่นำ n bits ไปยัง single bit ที่ไม่ใช่ทั้ง constant และ balanced แต่ในปัญหานี้ เรา
ได้รับสัญญาว่าไม่มีฟังก์ชันเหล่านั้นอยู่ใน black box ฟังก์ชันที่อยู่ใน box นั้นรับประกันว่าเป็น constant
หรือ balanced Deutsch-Jozsa circuit หน้าตาคล้ายกับ Deutsche's algorithm แต่มี qubit มากกว่า นี่คือ
implementation ของ Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm เพื่อเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับ three-bit function คราวนี้เรามีสาม qubit
สำหรับ input state แทนที่จะมีแค่หนึ่ง และแล้วเรามี qubit สุดท้ายนี้สำหรับ output state ตามที่
ก่อนหน้านี้อีกครั้ง เราเตรียม input qubit ทั้งหมดให้อยู่ใน state 0 + 1 และ output qubit
ให้อยู่ใน state 0 ลบ 1 แล้วแม้ว่า math จะซับซ้อนกว่านิดเพื่อตาม แต่หลักการ
ยังคงเหมือนเดิม ถ้าฟังก์ชัน constant มันจะไม่ขึ้นอยู่กับ qubit สามตัวบนสุดเลย ดังนั้น state ของพวกมัน
จะ transform กลับไปยัง 0 หลังจาก Hadamard ตัวที่สอง และการวัดของเราจะให้ three-bit string ของ 0 ทั้งหมด
แต่ถ้าฟังก์ชัน balanced แล้วเมื่อเราวัด qubit ตามหลัง Hadamard กลไก phase kickback
จะทำให้ bit หนึ่งหรือมากกว่านั้นเป็น 1 อาจจะไม่ง่ายที่จะเห็นคราวนี้ แต่ถ้าคุณทำงาน
ผ่านแต่ละขั้นตอนด้วยตัวเอง คุณจะเห็นเร็วๆ ว่านี่ต้องเป็นกรณี วิธีหนึ่งในการตรวจสอบสิ่งนี้คือลอง
คำนวณความน่าจะเป็นของการวัดได้ 0 ทั้งหมดด้วยฟังก์ชัน balanced คุณควรได้ความน่าจะเป็นเป็นศูนย์ มา
รัน Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมด้วย Qiskit ขั้นตอนที่ยากที่สุดอาจเป็นการสร้าง Deutsch-Jozsa
function นั่นจะเป็น black box ที่เรา query ที่นี่ code นี้สร้าง Deutsch-Jozsa function สุ่มที่
รับประกันว่าจะเป็น balanced หรือ constant แล้วเราสร้าง Deutsch-Jozsa circuit โดยใส่ black box
function ของเราตรงนี้ อีกครั้ง เราเรียก circuit ด้วย sampler และหลังจากวัด เราดูที่
bit ที่วัดได้เพื่อกำหนดว่าฟังก์ชัน balanced หรือ constant
ถ้าทั้งหมดเป็น 0 มัน constant แต่ถ้ามีอย่างน้อยหนึ่ง bit เป็น 1 ใน string แล้วมัน balanced ใน
กรณีนี้ เราได้ bit string ของ 1, 1, 1
ดังนั้น เรารู้ว่าฟังก์ชัน balanced ฉันหวังว่าฉันได้ให้คุณเห็นภาพแรกว่า quantum algorithm
สามารถใช้ประโยชน์จาก quantum phenomena ที่น่าสนใจและมักละเอียดอ่อนได้ยังไงเพื่อให้ได้ข้อได้เปรียบเหนือ classical
algorithm คุณคงสังเกตเห็นด้วยว่ามันยากแค่ไหนในการออกแบบ quantum algorithm แม้แต่ algorithm
ตัวแรกก็ยังต้องใช้ความคิดสร้างสรรค์มากเพื่อให้ชนะ classical method ได้พอประมาณ และตั้งแต่ algorithm แรกนั้น
นักฟิสิกส์และนักวิทยาการคอมพิวเตอร์ก็ยังคิดค้นวิธีการที่สร้างสรรค์อย่างไม่น่าเชื่อในการใช้กลศาสตร์ควอนตัม
ให้เป็นประโยชน์ รวมถึง extension และ application เพิ่มเติมของ Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm ถ้าอยากรู้
เกี่ยวกับบางอย่างเหล่านี้ รวมถึงลอง Deutsch และ Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm ด้วยตัวเอง ไปที่
module ที่ลิงก์ในคำอธิบายเพื่อเริ่มต้น ขอบคุณที่ดู แล้วเจอกันครั้งหน้า